I was on my way home one evening,
quite late at night, on the bus,
so I wasn't paying much attention
to what was going on around me.
Until I suddenly looked down
and realised that the man sitting
next to me had his hand on my leg.
He moved his hand upwards
and grabbed me in the crotch.
Because I was on the phone
to my mum, I said
'I'm on the bus,
this man just groped me.'
And everybody on the bus heard me.
And everybody looked away.
Nobody stepped in.
No-one challenged him.
No-one even made
eye contact with me.
And it sent me such
a powerful message.
It felt like they were saying,
"We don't want anything to do
with this. This is your thing."
It made me feel that I was at fault,
that I'd done something wrong.
I felt incredibly embarrassed
and ashamed and confused,
and I got off the bus
at the next stop
and walked the rest of the way home.
Looking back,
I wasn't the only person
who got such a powerful
message that night.
So did the man who groped me.
He got the message,
"You can get away with this."
It sent the message that
this was just acceptable.
We're so used to receiving
the message from all around us
all the time, that women and girls
are sexual objects.
That our bodies are public property
and that we really are the sum
of our individual parts.
There are witchcraft cases
from Europe 400 years ago
where, for example, a woman
was accused of witchcraft
for giving a man a
'permanent erection'.
The idea that men couldn't possibly
be expected to control themselves
is nothing new.
But it's also something that's still
really impacting people's lives,
even today.
Now were you able
to wear undergarments?
You're like the fifth person
that's asked me that today.
Well, no, because,
is it inappropriate?
-To ask somebody what kind
of underpants they wear?
-I didn't ask you what kind.
You just asked me
if I was wearing any.
-Could you?
-No, what do you wear underneath?
What do you wear
underneath something...
Overalls.
-Do you wear clothes?
You wear dungarees. You can't wear
clothes under it it's like a wetsuit.
-Practically.
-OK, so you answered my question.
Well I don't know, maybe it's
a little bit more than a wetsuit.
Was I wearing underwear?
I mean, gosh.
I think the defensiveness here
is really key.
This idea that he is
immediately reaching to say,
"Well I haven't done anything wrong,
you're overreacting."
And that he kind of gets
a little bit of support for that
from her male co-star, and this
is something that we see a lot of,
that if women try to challenge
this kind of thing, try to speak out,
often there can be a closing of ranks
in a sense of, "No, no, no, you
don't get to be upset about this."
In most British homes,
parents clearly differentiate
between their sons and daughters.
But not in this
north London household.
Here they aim to bring up
their children
in what they call a non-sexist way.
I think what's really sad
watching this now
is that it still feels a
little bit revolutionary.
Wouldn't be fair for all the girls
to buy princesses
and all the boys
to buy superheroes.
Why?
Because girls want superheroes
and the boys want superheroes.
And the girls want pink stuff
and the boys don't want pink stuff.
-Yeah.
She makes it sound so simple,
doesn't she?
How is it possible
that this child gets it
and yet every time a large retailer
agrees to stop gendering its toys
or its children's clothes
as for boys or for girls,
you'll see a backlash in the press?
These kinds of stereotypes that
are so insidious and so low-level,
they are so often dismissed
as not a big deal.
In reality all we're saying is that
kids should have the choice.
That, just as she says,
some girls might like princesses
and some might like superheroes,
but shouldn't they have the option?
The reality is that fewer than one
in ten of our engineers is female,
and our Royal Society, one of our
biggest scientific institutions,
has never had a female president.
So no, of course these things aren't
the end of the world on their own,
but do they contribute to a world
in which girls are very, very gently
and slowly told, "This isn't for you,
this isn't for you"?
Of course they do, and actually
the end effect is quite extreme.
Andy, Sam is the first US player to
reach a major semi-final since 2009.
How would you describe--
Male player.
I beg your pardon?
-Male player, right?
-Yes.
We are seeing an increasing
number of male role models
who are choosing to step in
and just to mention this stuff
when it happens.
Not necessarily in a particularly
aggressive or angry way,
but simply just mentioning it
so that that isn't allowed to stand.
If you haven't experienced
sexism yourself,
like with other
forms of prejudice,
it becomes much easier to ignore
and to deny the reality
of its existence.
It's easy to suggest that
people are overreacting,
that they must
be making something up,
because you haven't seen it.
Essentially, the truth is
that we can't change this
as long as everybody just
thinks it's normal.